the united kingdom did not vote on
austerity policies or on the
insufficient protection of the borders
the united kingdom is not a member state of
the euro therefore the policies of the euro do
not apply to the kingdom  united the
united kingdom is not part of the
schengen zone so the united kingdom is in
control of its borders so don't
tell us stories that is to
tell us stories Mr farrage
you told a few days ago  that
you were wrong about the
budgetary aspects of the British issue to the
Europeans
if you had said that before the vote
I could have congratulated you but you
lied you did not tell the truth
you restored the truth
I  loved sir farrage debating with
you we have the same sense of humor
you have me I have one I
very much regret that this is the last time
we can debate since you
are not going to become